ich darf nicht leiden
ich wollte eigentlich einen tischkicker
mit ihnen basteln aber thema
gleichberechtigung fängt er bei der
sprache angepasst wenn alle tisch
kickerin das cool ist eigentlich oder
einer tischen kickertisch in kickerin ja
genau das muss man aber in kicker im
sprechen weil das ein gender gap ist das
städtchen das dann zwischen den
geschlechtern
sie haben vier söhne oder ja wie passt
das zu diesem frauenquoten credo bei den
grünen war ja es war der süden mussten
als täglich dahin halten die frauenquote
kommt jetzt so hinterher langsam was
haben sie noch einmal töchter oder was
nein aber die bühne bringen
alle frauen merken wir machen dann hier
in kleinen so schnell bereit wo spieler
dran kommen und dann können wir am
schluss noch einen kleinen match
gegeneinander spielen ist quasi dann am
ende der play station ohne strom
die grüne distanziert sich extrem von
nationalismus wäre es nicht gut wenn
deutschland einfach sich blamieren würde
beide wm das noch einen grund weniger
gibt um auf seinem land stolz zu sein
und ich jetzt mal politisch antworten da
finde ich die dreistigkeit mit der die
freude am spiel von rechts genommen wird
schon ein bisschen anstrengend ja
eigentlich ist es ganz schön zu sagen
wir sind die fans also sport haben sie
da auch noch eine gruppe oder stehen ja
die ist ja die habe ich vorher auch sie
dürfen sie auch benutzen die ist einfach
zu mega super wieso muss man den ich
links sein um die umwelt schützen zu
wollen da muss man nicht ganz viele
rechte und auch ganz viele rechte rechte
sind die schau mal umweltschützer dann
ist ja ganz schön ganz schön gefährlich
das ist dann von umweltschutz zu heimat
und dann glück und bodenschutz geht das
ist nicht schwierig also was wäre ihnen
denn lieber ein rassistischer
tierschützer mit einem sehr kleinen
ökologischen fußabdruck oder ein super
liberaler mensch der flüchtlinge
aufnimmt und dann in seinem privatjet
mit denen um die welt die es dann nimmst
im privatrecht da so wenig es ihnen die
umwelt an wert
privat kann nicht wegnehmen autoritär
denkende leute die nicht mehr erreichbar
für eine liberale gesellschaft für euch
im netz ihr die ihr dazu schaut
hinterlasst doch einen daumen nach oben
oder schreib doch in die kommentare
was der herr haarweg privaten mal
basteln sollte alle probleme die die
umwelt hat sind von menschen selber
gemacht also wäre es nicht einfach
längerfristig an der zeit sich vom
menschen als konzept zur farblichen
umgekehrt ist es glaube ich richtig wir
müssen uns klar machen dass wir die
umwelt nicht schützen weil die umwelt
das braucht sondern weil die menschen
das brauchen die umwelt kann uns alle
gut überleben haben die in serie
überlebten texaner spricht oder
irgendwas irgendwelche arten werden neu
entstehen das ist dann der körper diese
wäscheklammer wäscheklammer für die
leute zu hause
das hat man damals noch benutzt als
privat noch nicht gab und man seine
klamotten mehr als tragen musste vors
tor kommt ein spieler des sc torwart
manier neueren genau dass manuela oder
manuela neuer können wir auch sagen dann
passt es und dann kommt der kopf dran
und das muss sondern festkleben wie
würde fußball
ich glaube es gibt sogar grüne
fußballmannschaft terminen und das sind
dann sehr ähneln und frauen in den
frauen nicht okay spielen sie selber
eigentlich auch fußball als die kids
kleiner waren natürlich viel mit dem
slogan geburt hätten wir das mit
töchtern auch gemacht durch stimmt ja
auch gegen ihren willen
wenn die das nicht gewollt dann hätte
ich mit denen weiß ich nicht dann was
machen die keine ahnung haben sie in die
kommentare was machen eigentlich mädchen
in ihrer freizeit wenn ihr ziel und
annalena baerbock nachspielen können sie
ihren ganzen namen eigentlich sagen kann
nach immer wärmer aber die hat noch zwei
stimmt zweiten und einen dritten
das weiß ich aber nicht die heißt anna
lena charlotte alma hamburg wissen sie
was die sozial davon sind anna lena
charlotte in d a ch
acab es ist das noch in die kamera sagen
ja das hat die denn für eltern
wahrscheinlich solche wie mich die nicht
wussten dass das eine absolution für
euren kopf verbessert so ich dachte sie
sind zwar cool die eltern von ihr aber
jetzt stimmt wahrscheinlich sind die
recht einfach nicht informiert jetzt
kommen die köpfe drauf wir hatten auch
politiker köpfe nehmen können natürlich
dann wäre das so verwirrend dass die
dann 100% rückgrat haben franck ja was
war gut sie haben philosophie studiert
dann haben sie ein paar bücher
geschrieben jetzt machen sie ein
bisschen politik was werden sie denn
geworden wenn sie was richtiges gemacht
hätten was wenn sie denn gewonnen wenn
sie nicht komikerin geworden stellt sich
ja ich denke schon aber haben sie das
irgendwie studierter vorbereitet ich
habe nicht angefangen das war jetzt aber
da haben sie gemerkt dass für ein
schlechter comedian ich bin das war
jetzt erstmal mit leidenschaft
vorgetragen und nicht in diesem motto
nimmer da dachte ich das muss jetzt
ernst sein
ja ja nein hinterkopf hat schon bald
nach hinten
das ist wie sie das wieder hatte sein
dass wir in bayern münchen co geschenkt
gekriegt und was hat er falsch machen so
dass er die 12 vorne ich ersticke
lätzchen hatte und irgendjemand schrieb
hilfe der mann hat seinen kopf verkehrt
rum
wir sind die nummer eingeben einer
kriegt die zwölf drauf das ist dann
söder
sie dürfen eigentlich nicht jetzt hier
ihre pr zeit nutzen um werbung für sie
da zu machen
das haben sie schon drei mal den namen
südufer das trikot richtigen assoziiere
ich habe mich dieses ph mäßig gefühl mal
kurz hier dienen dessen name nicht
genannt werden darf
ich würde sagen wir spielen jetzt eine
runde um was wollen wir spielen und mit
welchen die sich besser drehen meine
sind die ganz schön stramm für ihre sind
leichtgängiger habe ich mal für jedes
tor das man macht darf man den anderen
die wäscheklammer ins gesicht kleben er
ist viel zug drin
danke ich kann schlecht verlieren
wieso dann nicht in einer anderen partei
weil es dafür zu gewinnen gibt die
grünen eigentor hab hier k21 würde ich
sagen so können wir nicht aufhören
wir machen jetzt einen schnitt und dann
habe ich einfach 20 klammern im gesicht
dann stehen sie gut da ja das war ein
riesiger spaß viel spaß beim basteln
vielen dank fürs kommen robert habeck
alles gute man sieht sich ja würde
zunächst werden
[Musik]